lovely
are you you're doing the timings today
aren't you damon yeah
foreign
greetings now live chair thank you
good morning everyone welcome to today's
virtual
planning committee meeting before we
start i would like to confirm which
committee members are here
and the officers who will be supporting
us today
thank you chair in the meeting room with
us today we have councillor william
armitage
uh council jane barry councillor andrew
cooper
councillor mark foster councillor carol
huckabee
councillor mo potts council alan powell
councillor tracy reader councillor
jackie bridgeway
councillor kathy rouse councillor diana
ruff yourself
the chair of this meeting and councillor
ross shipman
also in attendance is uh councillor
heather liggett who is speaking today
on the second application and the
offices that are in the meeting room
are adrian kirkland who's the planning
manager richard purcell
who's the head of planning jenny owen
who's a solicitor to the council
uh myself nicola calf i'm the
government's manager and i'll be
facilitating this meeting
we have alan marr who is the clerk and
who will be and also members of the
governance team who are supporting today
and we have uh case officers for the
planning applications that will be heard
we have alice
lockett and graham cooper
thank you chair thank you
as you're aware this is only the second
time that the council has held a
planning committee
using the conference call software we
have a protocol in place for meeting in
this way which i would like
the meeting facilitator to read thank
you
so this is just reminding all members to
keep their cameras on throughout the
meeting
to behave as you would in the council
chamber following our rules of procedure
and the virtual the virtual meeting
standing orders as amended at the last
meeting of council
to speak through the chair for the
meeting to indicate you wish to speak by
raising your hand or
writing speak in the chat function to
introduce yourselves at all times
for example saying um counselor x
representing
x ward and just be mindful of your home
surroundings
voting will be done by roll call today
so this will be exactly how we would
normally do for a recorded vote in the
chamber
while i will call your names in
alphabetical order and if you can
indicate clearly
for against or abstain thank you chair
thank you the first item on today's
agenda is apologies for absence have we
received any in advance
yes chair we've received apologies from
councillor peter elliott
thank you no other apologies
non-received chair thank you
any declarations of interest
again non-received chair thank you
members are requested to declare the
existence of any nature of disposable
opportunity interests with others
not already on their register if any
item on the agenda
please withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time
and as alan said we haven't received any
so we can move on to item four
this moves us on to our main business
today item three consideration of the
planning application
as you can see each of the individual
applications has its own report and is
set out and the items
3a 3b and 3c i am happy with this and
intend to use it as our running order
however before we consider the first of
these i would like the clerk to explain
how the individual
applications will be dealt with
right thank you chair this is the
procedure for considering applications
at the meeting we will consider the
applications
in the order that they are set out on
the agenda although there will be a
short break between them
the chair will introduce the application
and ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments
or updates received since the agenda was
issued
the late items agenda supplement has
been published on the council's website
and the link has been sent to committee
members
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the sites
the screen showing this presentation
will be shared with those attending the
meeting
you can also see it on the council's
website through its youtube channel
following on from this the chair will
ask each of the speakers
any ward members first followed by
objectors then the applicants or their
agent
to speak to the committee each speaker
will have three minutes to put forward
their views
using the conferencing facility
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee
will have an opportunity to ask the
speaker questions if necessary
to clarify any points they have made
when we have heard from all speakers on
an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate
and for determination by uh vote
and not for speakers once the
application you've come to speak on has
been dealt with
you may leave the virtual meeting room
if you choose to remain however
then please mute your microphone and
turn off your camera
you will not be allowed to participate
further in the meeting
from that point now as you're aware this
meeting
is being live streamed the council will
make a recording for the purpose
of preparing the minutes once the
minutes have been approved by the
committee
then this recording will be deleted
please note however
that others may also record the live
stream from the internet
or the internet thank you chair
thank you we'll move on to the first
item
but before we start i just like to read
out
that in line with our normal practice
i'm going to ask the planning officers
to tell us about any late comments
reports that have been produced and for
the planning manager to give a brief
presentation
showing any photos and plans of the site
the meeting facilitator will share the
presentation on screen
this means that i might find it
difficult to see everyone
therefore i will allow the officer to
complete his presentation and ask
members to reserve any points of order
or questions
about the process until the end there
will be plenty of time for you ask
any questions later so we'll move on to
the first planning application
which is ned forward slash 20
000 nine five two one
hogarth rise drum field thank you
morning chair thank you um just two
advised members
i'll be taking members through the first
application my colleague
alice will take you through the second
one the copywood application at kelt
station then graham cooper
will take you through the town and
sherland application and of course
and i'll be able to uh to advise members
on questions further to that chair
just in terms of the the first
application that nikki is able to
share the presentation in due course but
just brief um introduction chair
and referring members firstly to the
late representation sent out yesterday
afternoon which
i'm sure members will have seen just in
terms of the introduction chair the
applicant
in this instance seeks consent to
construct a garden room within the
carthage
to the rear of his property the garden
room has been partially constructed
chair as you'll see
from the presentation a few seconds it
measures 10.5 meters long
and four meters wide at its greatest
extent
and that's width in terms of depth and
the plans
chair show the garden room to be 2.5
meters
high to eaves with lanterns in the roof
to provide additional light
for the to the windows it would be um
constructed
close to but not on the rear bound with
the property would extend across the
full width of the garden
the plans chair also show a decking area
to the rear of the recently extended
property and again we'll see that
in a few seconds the application site
chair is bound
by other residential units with those
three of the site those on
holborn closed chair being at a lower
level than the application property
itself again we'll see those
the photographs in a few seconds members
will have read sharing the officer
report that the development plan
policies relevant to the application
require such proposals to respect the
character appearance of the surrounding
area
and not be detrimental to the amenity of
neighbours and officers chair consider
that
both of those tests are met the reasons
that set out in the officer report
if nick is able to share the
presentation with you uh
chair i'll just just go through that
slide by slide
saw some of these uh plans and
photographs yesterday at the virtual
site meeting chair so some members will
be familiar with them
but if you just bear with me as i go
through them one by one
just the first slide chair ads is
customary we'll show you the
the application site and it's outlined
in the dark and it's the dark shaded
area if you just
go on to that mickey please so the
application site is the
dark shaded area you can see the
properties to the
north of the site they're the ones that
we support one are born close and they
are set at a lower level
to the application site they're
two-story in nature
the properties either side of the
application site
are single story and again we'll see
those in a second
thank you nikki this is a small scale
shot of what you'll see a larger
scale version of shortly the application
site outlined in red
the white um recta yeah that's uh
thank you nikki the the white box the
top end of the application site
that's the garden room the subject of
the application the application property
is the outlined black and white area to
the front of the site
into the middle of the site and then the
dark brown
area is the the decking area that we'll
see in a second
you can see the application room
details in the bottom right of that
slide showing
a pair of sliding doors in a window that
other windows refer to the officer
report that will face the
athlete applicant's own property there
are no other windows proposed and you
can just make out the
roof lanterns but otherwise there's a
flat roof
to the proper to the to the building i
say the height
weaves is 2.5 meters thanks nikki
this is taken from the west of the
application site looking from
the bungalow that we'll see the rear
elevation of in a second
but to the left of the
slide just behind where you can see the
tree
that's the location of the garden room
you can see to the rear of there the the
fencing that is fencing to the
rear of the properties on holborn close
which you can make out to the left
then on the right hand side the
immediate right
is a building within the applicant's
neighbor's property
and then beyond that you can see the
applicant's property and then
the further properties beyond that are
the the neighbors that's to number
23 so that's beyond the application site
these photographs were taken when the
case officer visited the site here
on the shirt and as we'll see in the
second um
the site has moved forward and beyond
that with the addition of some fencing
and these were taken back in the early
part of the year so that's i'm looking
towards the the rear of the site
excuse me the fencing that you can see
is that
the rear of the properties on holborn
close and in the
immediate front of the slide on the
right hand side
that's the decking area that's being
constructed
and then to the rear of the site is the
where the garden room would be located
thank you nikki this is looking back
from the application site towards the
nearest neighbour to the west the rear
outlook from from that property showing
the two windows looking towards the
application site
thanks nikki you will have seen from the
report chair that there is some dispute
regarding
where the construction is taking place
you can just see in the bottom
right of the right-hand photograph the
outline of where the garden room would
sit and the applicant is keen
for members to understand that he is
satisfied that the construction that's
taking place is on his
land and that's evidenced by the
photograph on the left where you can see
the wall of the property and then a
kickback to the extension and the rear
elevation of that they kicked back and
then the fence being built
behind the line of the wall of the side
of the property so the applicant is
satisfied
that the application site is within his
ownership or control
therefore chair further to that if there
is an ongoing dispute that is a matter
between the parties not a matter for
members to consider
this morning thanks nikki
this is just showing the outline the
right hand side the the
boundary wall and then the fence on top
of that the outline of the garden room
you can see just being
coming out of the ground beyond there
with the walling that would form its
boundaries and then beyond that is the
fencing
at the meeting yesterday chair there was
the the site visit meeting there was
some
questioning regarding the fencing i did
advise members
that any fencing over and above two
meters in height
would require planning consent otherwise
it is permitted development
but there is no no fencing um for me
part of the application
and no fencing shown on the submitted
plans either so that would be again a
matter
would be subject to any further control
planning commission was indeed required
for it thanks nikki
um on the left here you can see the rear
of the property the rear elevation
property with the
um the double doors that would form an
entrance into the property and which
were approved
previously under extensions granted the
development of the site and there's a
small patio area in the front which is
shown on the plans
the garden room is to the right in this
photograph beyond you can just see
next to the fence the the outline of
where the wall is coming out of the
ground
and the fencing as i say and we did have
questioning at the
site visit yesterday the virtual site
visit i did
advise members that anything above two
meters in height would require
planning consent in its own right and
due to
the cove restrictions that's not
something that has been investigated but
could be controlled through other means
other than this application
if that was the uh the issue chair if
members are minded to accept the officer
recommendation i do
think the best way of dealing with that
would be to put on an advisory note
saying with any fencing over and above
two meters in height
require funny consent in its own right
thanks nikki and just
uh and finally but one chair you can see
the outline on the left-hand photograph
here
the outline of the garden room and it's
at a lower level than where the
the photograph is taken as the any floor
levels of the
the existing house then on the right
chair there's a view
from that across the rear of the garden
again towards the
shed which is on the neighbouring
neighbouring property
outside the application site and then
finally nikki if you would
this is looking back from their chair
towards the applicant's property
the patio doors there are ones into the
property i'd say the area
in the foreground is the patio that's um
ancillary to that that proposal and the
fencing on the left
thank you chair
thank you are there any questions at
this stage
no oh counselor pal
councillor pal you're on mute still
yeah in reference to the slide which
shows the next door
shed um could the planning manager give
us any indication of
what the height of the new building
would be in relation to that shed in
other words is it taller
and roughly by how much
cherry regrettably i've not been able to
go onto the site myself due to the
the covid restrictions but the garden
shed chair would would normally be
in the region of 1.8 to 2 meters high
so that would be my my uh estimate of
its high chair
and as i've just mentioned um the
garden room would have a height to eaves
and then a flat roof beyond that of 2.5
meters so i think the
the garden shed will give an estimate of
um approximately the
the garden room being approximately um
i would say one and a half to two feet
so so
no 500 millimeters 50 centimeters higher
than
the garden shed but um just to to um
and make it clear to members chained to
council powell unfortunately i've not
been able to go on site myself due to
the to the kobe decision so i've not
actually measured
the garden shed but that would be my
estimate chair
thank you thank you councillor potts
that was exactly the question that i was
going to ask but if i if i may ask an
alternative while i while i have the
floor is it possible uh
adrian when you talk about um the
maximum height of the fence being
permitted to be two meters is that two
meters from the base of that wall
or is it two meters from the top of the
wall
upwards um
no chairs two meters from ground level
as i mentioned chair on the the drawings
and well just just to go back in the
history permission has been granted for
extensions to the applicant's property
and that did show
um patio doors to the rear so i think
it's reasonable to expect some
patio area to be formed from there and
as you could see on the photographs
the fencing in my opinion
is reasonable to require to ensure no
overlooking from there to neighbors
but beyond there as again and as i've
just mentioned to council powell we've
not been on site myself so i don't know
the height of
the projected fencing but um so i don't
know how high
the the post that you saw on photographs
is
but as i said there's nothing in the
application details or on the plan
showing fencing
so i think it would be reasonable to
expect that to be controlled if
otherwise members are supportive of the
garden room
to advise the applicant that anything
above two meters in height would require
planning consent
thank you uh councillor armitage then
councillor shipman
thank you chair uh it's a question for
adrian really
uh what uh what's the percentage uh
uh increase in the footprint uh
of the actual site
as i've just mentioned it is only um
it's not precise because as you'll have
seen from the drawings there is a
kickback in the width or the depth of
the garden room
but at its greatest extent it's four
meters and the width
of that sorry the the length of it
across the rear boundary is 10.5
so i'm guesstimating it's somewhere
around about
40 square meters
right it's not precise because i'd say
that the garden room is
um of an l shape with a slight kickback
but it's its greatest
depth it's four meters it's greatest
length it's 10.5 meters so
so it's going to be around about 40
square meters
thank you councillor shipman thank you
chair um
i just wondered if you knew because on
the application adrian it says that the
way that they're going to dispose of
sewage
is unknown is that because that they're
not planning to dispose of any sewage
from this garden room or because they
are not aware of how they're going to do
it yet
that changed since the application was
playing as council
shipment says chair the the details on
the application form identified as
there's no known um
uh no stated method of the disposal of
the foul sewage
i've taken it um council shipment that
there is no intent to have that sort of
facility in the in the garden room
but in terms of how surface and foul
water
would be dealt with if foul water was an
issue and clearly
surface will be that will be matter that
would normally on on something of this
scale be dealt with purely and simply
through the building regulations so we'd
need to make sure there is adequate
disposal of surface water
thank you i believe we've only got one
speaker for this
application it's an objector a steve
hibbert
mr hibbert you have three minutes okay
you just want me to start if you just
like to confirm your name and then you
start it'd be three minutes
uh my name's steve hibbert my egyptian
objection to this application in three
parts firstly the planning policies
design and landscape impact
the building is not a summer house as
described in the application
there's no way does it reflect that type
of building
but rather additional living or office
space
the application states that it's for
domestic use
but he has registered his business stop
solutions at 21 hurdle flights
this thesis conclude that the property
will be used for commercial purposes
having looked at the planning
information it states that over 50
percent of the land is to be built upon
planning commission is required there
will be significant
more than 50 build spawn which must
affect the drainage
of surface water as a result of this
application
of parts of the overall project being
separate you
as planners can't assess the impact of
this over development
secondly the character of the
neighborhood
impact on it number 21 is positioned at
a pinch point entrance to a call back
on the inside of the curve even with the
reduced amount of work being done
recently
we've been able to see on a regular
basis both private and construction
vehicles parked outside
often blocking the only pavement this
means the entrance to call this act is
reduced
the block payment has significant impact
on the safety of pedestrians
as they have to walk around in the
middle of the road
it's viewed by many people as the end of
the cul-de-sac
leads to a rural footpath this is part
of the link paths for the drumfield
ground wall
which has been used more than ever at
the current time
lastly regarding the attitude and
honesty of the applicant simulation
planning matters
although it is accepted the building
work starting in faith
the application form submitted states
incorrectly work hasn't started
i feel it is also important to advise
the committee
but although told to stop work it has
continued despite no
planning decision having been made
mr thought previously previous planning
applications granted on the basis that
although parking was to be lost a large
garage was included
however this has not been however
accommodation was built instead as
evidenced in the diagram
on slide five with this application
the applicant was told by enforcement
yeah
thank you you need to submit
suspected planning commission for this
change and as yet
a year later he has not to me this shows
the applicants have no regard for the
planning process
and any stipulations made are unlikely
to be followed
thank you thank you
councillor ralph sorry i didn't realize
you wanted to speak first before we go
for questions
okay thank you all it was um the
gentleman is actually touched
on what my question was um i did mention
this yesterday
um regarding having a condition is there
a condition we can actually put on
that because my belief as it looks it
could be turned into an annex
um but somewhere else is the summer
house people have their own
ideas and opinions of that and i'm just
wondering if there's any conditions that
we can place on that
to make sure it's not used as an annex
yeah i'm happy to come back to
councillor rouse on that point
but i'd um i don't want to uh subvert
process
for any questions that members may have
for mr hibbard to
chair thank you thank you are there any
questions for mr hibbert
councillor shipman
thank you chair um i just wanted to know
if mr hibbert was aware of any
additional flooding issues that had
occurred since because obviously
development seems to have already
started on this site and the floor plan
is already being concreted
in i wondered if he'd noticed on any of
the adjacent properties
or had evidence of the fact that they'd
been flooding onto his or any of his
neighbor's property
i've not mine i'm next door but one i
know
um somebody in our bank closes face to
send an email makes an objection due to
the fact that he is
two meters below he's concerned that
there might be flooding onto his
property
we've not also we've not had much rain
recently
thank you any further questions
thank you mr hibbett
are there any further questions for the
planning officers
i'm happy chair at this point to to come
back to a councillor rouse if you'd like
me to yes that's fine thank you just in
terms of the
the issue about the the business use
which i think is is the issue that
council rails is raising chair
the applicant is seeking consent for a
building ancillary to the use of the
property as a domestic property and not
as a business operation
so if there were to be any change in the
use of the property to
uh to mix use for just a purely
residential use to a mixed use
residential and business
property then that would require
planning consent of course you
may um use your house as we're all doing
this this morning for other purposes
other than just being a
residential property providing you don't
change the character appearance of the
dwelling house and many people do
use a room or rooms within the house to
uh
to to work from home for example as a
number of us are doing at the moment and
that wouldn't require planning consent
however just getting to the point that
the cancer house has
specifically raised officers are content
that the
building would be used in conjunction
with the house and some not
and require a change of use but just in
in this case in view of the comments
that have been made
officers are recommending chair just for
the sake of clarity and completeness at
condition three
that the outbuilding shall be used only
for ancillary domestic use
and not for any business use itself so
whilst um technically the condition is
not essential it may in this case uh
chair provide
um members with the the comfort that the
local planning authority would
retain control over the use of the
building as such
thank you are there any further
questions
counselor foster
yeah a question for the planning manager
uh how have you satisfied yourself that
this is to be used as a summer
somehow and it's not just an extension
to the building
and it won't be used for uh
business purposes thank you
just on that point chair the um
officers are taking the the application
on its face and it's made as a
ancillary outbuilding in connection with
the house as such
and we've dealt with it as such in our
device planning committee as well that
you should deal with it
in that that frame just on the
just get back to what i've said to
council rouse um just
previously if there is any change of use
of the the premises
to a an activity that's beyond what you
would normally expect
as a domestic property then that would
be something that would require planning
consent in its own right and i believe
share that could be dealt with
through the proper channels if and when
that would take place
thank you if we were to recommend this i
would like one other
um condition put in adrian and that's
regarding the height of the fencing
when you look at those pictures it does
cast quite deep shadows into the
neighboring gardens just to ensure that
they do
meet the actual height standard
okay what i'd suggest is if members are
minded to grant consent but
we um frame the condition and should
members wish it that
notwithstanding any submitted details
the height of any fencing
shall not exceed two meters in height
chair
thank you are there any further
questions
okay i think then this is where we move
for a motion
so we've completed all our discussions
what we've heard and what we think
and what we would decide but before
going on further we'd just like the
clock to remind us about the motions
all councilor powell's waving at me
sorry councillor pal
you're i'm you're still muted counsellor
i'm not making a murder at this um at
this point
but i'd just like to make a comment um
it's it's described in the application
as a summer house
or alternatively a garden room and
it's not like any summer house i've ever
seen um
it's a brick building with one window as
far as i can see
with lanterns to the roof um
the other point is it always concerns me
when there is a
an application which has got some
controversy
when the applicant chooses not to come
before the committee to be questioned
um and i think um i think that's quite
significant
so that's a comment i'd like to make
sure thank you
if i may just briefly come back on that
um as
members will have seen yesterday the the
applicant has submitted
further comments that were included in
the uh late update reports yesterday
which sought to address some of the
issues that have been raised in
mr hibbert's comments to members and in
the officer report
so the applicant has submitted that
chair in seeking to advise members on
some of those issues
thank you
arthur foster wishes to speak chat
counselor foster uh thank you chair i'm
not proposing emotion at this stage
but i feel a lot more comfortable
looking at something like this looking
at this application
for this brick built annex which looks
like an outbuilding
and not a summer house i feel much more
comfortable
giving my opinion on whether we should
give planning permission if it was
defined as what what it seems to be
if it was defined as an out building
um we can't say what uh what the
applicant's going to use it for that's
that's done in a matter of trust but i
feel much more comfortable
if it was defined as what it seems to be
in the plans it looks like a brick-built
building ever
i've seen the plans look to the the area
and it doesn't look like a summer house
um could ask from the planning manager
if it wasn't uh put down on the
application
as a summer house and it was described
as an annex
and further living area how would we
would we be treating this
thank you from our office point of view
chair
um we would be dealing with it in in the
same manner that we've
dealt with it as the description as a
garden room and in terms of
how members deal with the application i
i
don't i wouldn't advise members to get
too
um caught up in what was that what's
actually described in the application
form as as clearly as as councilor
powell was
articulated the building is as shown on
the drawing
yes it is a brick building with limited
windows to the front elevation and
mountains to the roof
i think members need to um consider it
on its face and what's shown on the
plans and
if it were described as a an out
building rather than as a guard room or
or an annex to the house
then planning officers would have
reported um
in the same way just the description of
the application would have changed
members need to consider the application
this morning on its face on the basis of
the submitted details
and to retain a consideration of it on
the basis of your development plan
policies irrespective of what the
application is titled share so i
understand um
the points that council powell and
council foster making in terms of how
it's described
but i don't think that should be the
determining factor for members
and officers retain the view that the
building is
shown and described as an ancillary
building to the main house
and if it were to be used for other
purposes that would require planning
incentive would be dealt with
the normal channels and members would
have the chance to
consider that then on its face at that
time
councillor armitage thank you chair
uh looking at this summer house
uh the size of it and also its
construction
uh i don't think it is a summer house at
all the uh footings are there
uh and again without uh planning
permission
at the time uh but that's nothing to do
with my
decision on this uh the
it's got a cavity wall as you would do
uh
with a a proper construction
for living accommodation according to uh
building regulations and
i would move to go against officers
recommendation
because this is no way a summer house
it's also the size of the building which
is
too large as well for the actual site i
think it's over development to site
helpful at this point if i um gave some
advice in terms of the
process for motions thank you
okay thank you chair uh please bear in
mind
members that a motion must be moved and
seconded before a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then that amendment will be
voted on
first if a motion is to be moved which
goes against officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving the motion
against offer officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject reject officer
recommendations fails
or in other words it is not passed and
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion in
favor of the recommendations
or another course of action this will
need to be approved by the committee
through another vote
before we have a motion um adrian
kirkham would like to speak
yes if i can come back if i may share
just uh specifically again to the points
that counselor armitage has made
i really need to uh to um
advise members that you need to consider
the planning merits of the application
and not necessarily what it's described
as
or what it's called on the application
form or what you feel that the applicant
may do with the building subsequent to
any permission that's granted
you need to consider the application on
its face and on its merits
as a building that's proposed in the the
rear garden of a property
and also you need to avoid considering
or
being led by the fact that the
development has started that isn't a
matter for
you to consider you need to consider the
application on its merits
now counselor armitage has mentioned
size of the building and
potential over development but again
chair
members need to consider why those
points may be harmful
what interest do they harm because a
building of a size
maybe it may be large but that doesn't
necessarily make it
unacceptable it needs to have some harm
or some impact on something of
importance
and normally a public interest and not
only not just a private interest
and i have to say chair i've not yet
heard
um any consideration of any harm that
the building
would cause to neighboring properties or
the character of the area
which are the issues that you need to
assess and which are set out in your
development plan policies
um cancer army just said talked about
over development
but why is that necessarily an issue
here why is that harmful
what interest does it impact on and so
chair just to
ask members to take their decision on
the planning merits of the application
not be too concerned about how it may be
described or what a future use may be
you need to consider it on its merits
and on its face
and what harm the building has on any
interest of importance
thank you chair councillor shipman then
councillor foster then we really ought
to move on
thank you chair um i'm really struggling
with
taking this application on it's very
because if you take it on its merits
the applicant's saying that there's been
no development taken place so far and
clearly
there has been development taken so far
so if we are taking it on its merit
we've got an applicant that's trying to
mislead this committee as far as i can
see
um in terms of what planning issues this
applicant
could potentially have if you allow this
call it summer house guarding house
greenhouse whatever you want to call it
if you if we allow this on this property
with
the size of foot and it has i think the
the the cumulative effect that if for
example the neighboring properties then
it want to also
put their own in on um an area that's
got an elevation like this where
flooding
could go down the hill and flood
properties that are lower down
we could easily create an issue
uh for not only those residents at the
top of the hill but those at the bottom
because you can end up you could end up
with 16
summarizes along the back end of their
property and all those that are lower
down
could end up with severe flooding issues
so for me if
we get if we're going to reject it which
i'm leaning towards at this moment in
time
it's got to be on the cumulative impact
of having a garden
somewhere else of that size
thank you councillor felster
yeah thank you chair further to
what counselor shipman and councillor
armitage shed
and from the advice we've had from the
planning
manager for me it's uh i'd consider this
over development
or overcrowding of the site i've made a
few notes here
uh in particular where where this is
it's out of character with the area when
you look at the rest of the house it's
completely out of character
so i consider it over development and
that there's a
negative visual impact here uh
when it's considered when you look at
the all the gardens and all the
buildings and take them as a whole
uh so for me a detrimental uh effect on
the
on the character of the local area uh
would there be sufficient grounds in the
planning manager's
view thank you
adrian i'm just i'm just going back on
council
fosters issues chair i'm mindful that um
you're wanting to
to move along and council fosters
mentioned out of character with the area
overdeveloped having a negative impact
unfortunately cats foster part of what
you said
you went silent on me so i missed a
little bit of
the the last couple of sentences if you
could just
outline those back to me but just to be
clear chair
and counselor fox's foster's point in
terms of out of character with the area
over development and negative impact i
just um would i think for cancer foster
may be going on to say why over
development was
and leading to that negative impact i
think well that will be important in
framing any reason for refusal if
members are minded to go in
in that direction just before cancer
foster comes back to chair if i may
i'm just on the point that councillor
shipman made about other development and
potentially other garden rooms
what may happen outside the auspices of
this application chair are not
matters for members to consider um
this morning there may be other
applications for guard rooms they would
be considered on their merits at that
time
and the only other point to just mention
the shipment mentioned about surface
water chair
i as as always i'd advise members to
steer clear of technical matters unless
you very
clear and sound evidence that there is a
technical issue that would be
disturbed by granting consent in this
case and i've not heard this morning any
evidence
why or how surface water disposal would
be harmful chair or why
adequate provision couldn't be made for
it but if council foster can just fill
me in on the
couple of sentences i'm afraid i didn't
hear apologize chair
yes chad would you like me to carry on
yes please too
uh yeah um for me it's it's the is the
visual impact
uh on the whole area um on the locality
uh that this would have a detrimental
effect on the character
of the whole area what it looks as it is
now it does look like an over
development
to me
thank you councillor shipman then
councillor barry
and councillor pots and then we really
must move for emotion we're way over
time here
thank you chair um i have to disagree
with adrian on this because actually
under
uh the mppf 49a
it says the develop the development
that's proposed is so substantial or its
cumulative effect would be so
significant that to grant permission
would undermine the planning-making
process by pre-determining decisions
about the scale
location and phasing of new development
that are central to an emerging plan
well if we were to pass this we would
literally be predetermined future
developments because if any
neighbors wanted to have a garden room
we would basically be giving them
we'd have to approve theirs if we're
approving this one so i would have to
disagree with adrian that we can't take
into account
although in other future applications
because we can't the mppf
says that explicitly
thank you adrian you want to come back
on that yeah
i can't add anything to what i've said
previously i know what council chip
shipment has said about the mppf but but
ultimately
each application must be judged on its
merits and
future applications need to be judged on
on their own merits and in terms of
um the issues that the councillor um
shipments made i i believe they are more
pertinent to the plan making process
rather than to applications such as this
chair thank you councillor barry
yeah adrian um am i right i'm saying
that we do have
enforcement officers that we can send
out to do
spot checks to see that something has
been
used for what it was meant to be used
for um so that if
if in a few months time or 12 months
time
uh we feel we we want to go under a spot
check that we can send an enforcement
officer out
yes chair if there is a breach of
planning control we do have enforcement
officers who could go and check upon any
concerns it's raised with us chair or
ultimately if um
yourself or the vice chair wished and
wish for us to to go out and make a
visit and say 12 months time we could
diary that in chair thank you
councillor parts
thank you chair my question is to the
uh to the planning manager have the
applicants included
this proposal um in the application that
was approved
in 2019 would
your recommendation have been the same
or would you have considered at that
point that this would have been
in excess of the permitted building to
be allowed
that's a difficult question to uh to
answer
council pots because um ultimately 2019
was 2019 and now it's 2020 but
i think my view would be
reacting to that question that yes we
would have
um sought to to recommend approval for
the whole scheme
it's all been submitted as one the the
applicant in this case as he set out in
his
representation result that was of the
view that
what he was constructing was permitted
development and
if he hadn't constructed the other
extensions it would have been it meets
all those other tests
but because of the other extensions this
proposal itself requires permission
because more than 50 percent of his
his garden curtains rather than just his
garden um
is to be constructed with buildings over
it
hope that that answers council boxes
question
thank you and if i'm going to ask the
clerk now to take us through the
correct procedure for a motion
yes just so far we've got um just
further what i've just said before
we've got a mover for a motion to um
go against officer recommendations
sorry do you want him to speak that
adrian
very briefly chair i've um i've noted
what to what council foster's um
specific issues were i was just going to
say uh alan before we
move to the vote if there is a
resolution to
um refuse the application that um the
final reasonings for refusal are based
on council foster's comments
but uh that's finalized in conjunction
with the chair and vice chair
chair that's the foster
i'm happy to second uh councillor
armitage's
uh motion and if much like the planning
manager said
if we do base it around sound reasons
sound solid reasons which what i've
spoken about just to go over it again
uh for me it's the size of the property
size of the building on the area it's
over development
uh it's out of character in that area
and it's got a negative an adverse
visual impact
uh on the locality and a whole
detrimental effect to the professor's
development on the character of the
local area
so if we can base it around that please
thank you councillor armitage if castle
amita just happy with that
yes uh i'm just going to say yes i'm
happy
to go along with council foster's
recommendations
on my basis chair then i think the
motion is to reject officer
recommendations
for the conditions as discussed which is
essentially around
size of the building over development
out of character
and uh detrimental to the uh wider area
is that largely captured
thank you um okay we need to take the
vote then by
uh poll um i'll take this over to nikki
carver
yeah so members um you are voting um
on a motion to go against officer
recommendation
i'm going to take you through um a vote
by roll call which would be the same as
if we were doing a recorded vote in the
chamber and i'll commence that in
alphabetical order if you could clearly
say
for against or abstain councillor
william armitage
uh i'm uh going against officers
recommendation
so that would be a vote for would it
counsel armitage yes
motion yes yes counselor barry
against
council cooper against
cancer mark foster
carol huckabee
councillor huckabee would you mind
unmuting yourself to give your vote
yes against
mopots cats and no pots
councillor alan powell
councillor tracy reader
councillor jackie ridgeway
against councillor kathy rouse
council diana ruff what are you going on
with
apologies there's somebody speaking i
could not hear councillor ross
again and councillor rosh shipman
okay i make that five votes four and
seven against
thank you so the motion has emotions
falling
thank you
clark would like to take us through the
next stage
yes then sure it's a matter of um there
has yet to be a motion for members to
um sort of vote on so given the fact
that the officer recommendations have
now
or the the amendment to the officer
recommendations have been um
rejected do members wish to make another
motion
i'd like to put forward a motion that we
recommend officers
accept represent to the officer's
recommendations with the conditions
supplied
that we've talked about previously
around the fencing
and the um 0.3 which is already on
which is about the use of the building
i'm not sure adrian if we can
uh condition into there about the
enforcement officers
um visits
that wouldn't be a condition chair if
members are minded to approve the
application what i'd
um suggest share and in conjunction with
yourself
this um diary visited by enforcement
officers in 12 months time
thank you i'll second the
motion put forward by councillor barry
so that the motion is then to approve
officer recommendations for the
conditions as discussed
and as set out in the report is that the
essence of it
yes thank you yes
very happy for me to lead a vote yes
please
okay members i'll take you through the
vote again so we're
uh voting on whether to grant permission
in line with
officer recommendations we're asking for
four against or abstain from that motion
counselor william armitage against
councillor jane barry
because for carol huckabee against
councillor mopots against
councillor alan powell
councillor tracy reader or
councillor jackie bridgeway for
councillor kathy rouse
that's the kathy rouse
uh counselor else you're muted
how's the diana rough
councillor ross shipman
yeah i make that six against and six
four
would you like to exercise um chairman's
casting vote
i will do it's for
therefore officer recommendations to
trump commission are carricher
oh
if we can move on to the next
application
which is the ash over which is ned4
slash
20140371
and it's the application for a side
extension
at cambrie wood kelstedge lane
so hand over to the planning officer
hello thank you chair
uh nikki have we got the um
yeah the screen thank you
okay so for clarity
uh this application has now been amended
to remove the doma windows and the
conversion of the loft and the new
garage so the proposal is now for a
single storey side extension
to the western elevation and the access
to the site will remain
as existing let me move to the next
slide please
carvery wood is located on the corner of
calstash lane and the a632 matlock's
chesterfield road at bellstone
is highlighted in orange on here
the properties within the settlement
development limited limits for calstage
as the bank um as the boundary runs
along calsius lane
and so the field to the north is in
countryside
the main policies that um we're looking
at here are um
h5 domestic extensions be1 general
design and gs5 settlement development
limits
and come over their next slide please
thank you
this slide shows the location plan the
property to the south
next to the a632 is the neighbor at the
cottage
the hedges discussed in the report are
along the boundary between the two
properties so that sort of southern
southwestern boundary uh come to the
next slide please
this slide shows the plans for existing
bungalow
with the garage to the east um it's
a bit faint but you should be able to
see the hedge in the bottom left hand
corner
on the boundary with the package that's
it yeah down there
thank you grab the next slide please
um where are we uh this
um sorry the proposed extension
will be on the western elevation and if
members of mine
needed to prove the application a
condition to retain the hedge in the
left-hand corner
behind the extension is proposed we can
have the next slide
please
here we have the plans and elevations
for the existing bungalow
and then in on the next slide um
yeah these are the plans and elevations
for the proposed extension as you can
see it will
result in a new wing to the bungalow but
there'll be no increase in height
the width of the new wing will be and
about 9.85 meters and it'll be about 13
meters at the deepest point
then we move on to photographs
okay and here you can see the existing
access point
uh and the view to the east was the a632
um next slide please
and this is the view going west uh along
carlstage lane
from the access point uh next slide
please
um so the extension is going to be added
to
um the western elevation of the property
the buildings you can see
behind there are agricultural buildings
next slide please
um so again this is another view of the
western elevation of the bungalow where
the extension will be located
and then the next slide this is the
front elevation
of the current bungalow um
and then that's the garage which will be
retained
um okay so this is another view of the
location of the extension
if you note the hedge at the boundary
with the footage
on the bottom there um
and then there's another one where it's
a bit closer i think
yeah this is a similar view and then
that that's the hedge a bit closer up so
you can see it's
uh it's about three meters high and it's
quite deep
uh next slide please
um
so uh there's some oh sorry could you
just go back one
sorry yeah so this is another view of
the site showing the agriculture
building to the right
and the reef of the croft
which is one of the houses on vernon
lane at the bottom there
and that's separated from the garden of
cardboardwood
and it's so garden by the garden of um
the cottage oh then last two are
just views from further away uh up the
a632
um if you're coming from chesterfield
i think that's all thank you chad
thank you i've lost my place now okay
are there any questions at this stage
yes counselor armitage
yeah could we go back to the first slide
uh when it says about the uh
the actual title of the application
still says
about dormer windows and things like
that all right
it may have been amended but the title
is still
uh you know with the global windows
yeah is it a technicality or what
really just come in on that to that
chat and first of all my apologies to uh
to members for that but yes as council
army just said it is
purely simply a technicality officers
have
negotiated a subsequent scheme with
the applicant chair and members are just
being asked to consider the extension
and no part of the roof as alice has
explained
or different garaging out whatever just
no longer forms part of the application
chair so
the report is is accurate in terms of
the
detailing set out there it sought to um
assess the um application as
now considering the title and the
committee report is is correct so i
apologize chair that the
title on the presentation is of the
original application
and doesn't reflect what has been
negotiated subsequently
thank you but that if i just come in
that's the application uh which we
always said
the application uh which is on the table
and you know we that's what the one that
we're deciding on surely because it's uh
uh incorrect uh as people would
like to say i don't know where we stand
on this
chad just so it can be absolutely clear
chair in in that respect council
armatures is incorrect
that the application before you is that
it has been
negotiated by officers i apologize again
that the
title on the presentation and was taken
from the originally submitted forms
but the matter before memphis is purely
simply the extension as alice has
outlined
to you just now and you've no need to
consider anything that
formed part of the basis of the
applications originally submitted
so the matter before you is clear chair
you're able
and to make a clear decision on that on
its planning merits
and you need only consider the extension
and
um in terms of the report that's before
you that is correct and full and gives
you all the information that you need to
have to consider to determine the
application
okay i i accept your uh
uh apology on that okay
okay we have i believe what
alan did you want to speak sorry
counselor pal
okay thank you i believe we have one
speaker an
objector linda kamcar
i can't see
shipment and then we'll move on to uh
linda
thank you chair um i just wondered if
one of the planning officers could
explain to me why or if they're aware
why
dcc originally said that they wanted the
entrance moving
or seemed to have changed their mind
now um say and said that they've got no
objection because originally
dcc did actually object quite to quite a
few things and the report
that's been given to members don't
really highlight that was their original
um objections to it um
and i find it a bit strange that this
theme just because the garage has been
removed the visibility coming out of
that property seems to have improved
i'm i'm i'm a bit lost on that fact
um and i'm also it concerns me the dcc
have also said
that they they've guessed that the
traffic will be around 50 miles per hour
even though they've carried out no
traffic survey
well if they're not looking at the road
how can they determine exactly how
fast people are pulling off a632
excuse me i mean they're fairly big um
issues would it be better to
answer them after mrs kamkarz had the
opportunity to speak
i'm happy with that if councillor
shipman's happy with that
yeah no problem chair thank you thank
you uh mrs kamcar
if you'd like to speak you have three
minutes from when you're ready
thank you my name is linda camcar and i
live at the cottage ashover road
which neighbours the carbury woods site
the proposed development is to extend
the property by almost a third of the
original site
the extension would provide a
five-bedroom bungalow
which would include a vast master
bedroom ensuite and dressing room
which is approximately 30 meters 13
meters in length
i consider this would make the whole
building out of character with other
properties in the neighborhood
and as a result will have a detrimental
impact on the landscape
due to the over the development in the
side of the site
and the loss of garden space
it would not be unrealistic to assume
that the proposed development
consisting of five bedrooms would house
a minimum of five
people therefore one would expect there
to be numerous cars at this site
due to the driveway being in close
proximity with a very busy a632
and next to a blind corner it would
prove
prove hazardous and dangerous to other
road users and pedestrians
if there is no footpath when cars are
exiting and entering the site
there is also a hedge bordering carbary
wood
and my property and it runs the entire
length of the site
there has to be no mention of what the
intentions are regarding the main
center hedge and the upper portion of
the head in the planning application
and the photograph that has been
submitted only shows
the lower hedge numerous birds and
wildlife
live in that hedge and it is quite deep
these sections of the hedge should these
sections of the hedge be removed it
would have a detrimental impact to the
wildlife and
inhabitants of these hedgerows and the
windows of cardberry wood
would look directly into my garden and
into another neighbor's property
the upper section of the hedge which
also borders my property
marked as a fence on the plans although
it has been a hedge
for at least 15 years and probably well
over 20
is situated to the side of my first
floor decking area
should there be any removal of this part
of the hedge and the trees
then not only would wildlife again be
affected
but my upper decking would be unusable
due to the lack of prized [ __ ] as
anyone's problem
as anyone on my decking would not only
be visible to the inhabitants of carbury
wood
but also to anyone using kel stage lane
and anyone driving down
matlock road and passing through kelp
stage
it would have a detrimental impact on my
privacy
should any of these hedges be removed
thank you
thank you
shall we ask mrs cartmore any questions
before we go back to councillor shipman
thank you
any questions
no members are indicating they wish to
ask a question chair
thank you mr cam mrs kamcar that's all
for now thank you
thank you back to you councillor shipman
yeah it was just my concerns a about the
fact that
i mean dcc did object to begin with
about the access
um off kel stage lane um
so i think that that's probably worth
mentioning so members are aware if you
look at the original objective
talk about visibility coming onto
killstone's lane um
and you know pulling on and off of there
they also do actually make
um this they talk about um
cars will be traveling at 50 mile an
hour down kelstro's lane
um but they admit themselves that
they've done no um
traffic survey which i find bizarre to
even them to make that statement
because again it's leading us to believe
that that
that cars are traveling at 50 miles an
hour when clearly they they don't know
that for a fact
and i think that it's not quite right
that they're telling us that as a
planning committee
so i just wondered if the officers had
been
informed of anything from dcc as to why
they've made this massive u-turn on the
visibility from the entrance
um even though no um amendments have
been made to that part of the
application
um and why um and
if if they would give the fight anyway
the fact that dcc is saying
traffic controlling the 50 mile an hour
given the fact that they've not done
anything to substantiate that
can i respond chair please certainly
right certainly carry on i'm sorry
so the original application had
um a different access point to the west
further west along the boundary um
where where there was going to also be
um
a detached garage
um and that's what dcc objected to
they were concerned that you there
wasn't space to turn around
and there wasn't a good visibility from
that access point
the new uh the amended plan sorry um
uses the existing access point which dcc
are happy is sufficient
just add to that um chair in terms of
the
the issue that counts the shipment
raising which members
um are well within the rights to
consider the issue of highway safety
as alice has just explained the
originally submitted application
proposed a new access point so there
would have been two accesses
whereas now and through the amendments
that have been secured by officers only
one would
remain and the fact that uh
a speed survey hasn't been done i don't
believe chair
is um overriding in this case for
members because
the extension will be used in
conjunction with the house that would be
remained at the single access point in
us and many members will probably know
um cal stage lane
i think by its very nature and we'll
have limited um
traffic speeds along it and the access
is in
close proximity to its junction with the
matlock chesterfield road
so vehicles either approaching it or
leaving the main
road into kel stage lane um from
my experience then in my opinion would
be traveling at very low speeds
and potentially not in excess of 50
miles an hour i'd be surprised
happy to uh discuss further highway
issues as appropriate
uh chair but i um firmly of the
the belief chair that um this proposal
will not have a severe impact on highway
safety
um in this location and on the basis of
the submitted details
thank you chancellor armitage thank you
chair
it was on highway safety
if you remember on a previous
application
uh which was uh uh
the appeal was dismissed and the uh
inspector did mention that
they had concerns about the entrance
and the visibility displays
bearing in mind that the entrance which
is on the plan
now is only a few yards from the main
road
and something else which uh has come to
a notice
is that nothing's been mentioned about a
turning
area whereby the cars concerns
have to go out nose first rather than
going out backwards because if they go
up backwards
it will certainly be an accident waiting
to happen
and there's no nothing on the plan
to give turning area you can probably do
a three
point or a 23 point turn
on the actual thing but there should be
a designated
air turning area so that people can
turn the vehicle round and
enter for um exit forward
uh because that road is uh
very narrow and there isn't a turn well
if you go down that road you have to go
for about a mile before you can turn
around even
it was just an observation
yeah i don't know if nicki is able to
bring that the presentation and allow us
to have a look at
a site plan if members wish to discuss
that tissue
the counselor armitage is raised in
terms of turning chair but
um you'll have seen from one of the
photographs that there is quite a
significant area
of um hard standing in front of the
garage it's just um
a few slides onto the photographs first
if you can uh
nikki just um uh keep going to the one
that there's one of the garage that that
one there
that shows uh a vehicle already on the
site
and and a large area part standing so i
would agree with cancer armitage that
vehicles would be able to
um turn within the site and come out in
in a forward
gear chair so i'd be concerned if
members were
so concerned about that matter that that
[Music]
was relied on significantly in
determining the application
just finely chain in terms of the um the
appeal
decision that councilor armitage refers
to that was um in relation to
a new dwelling house which would have
created
its own issues and considerations rather
than the extension to an existing
so i don't think the two are comparable
in any in any case or low chair
i'm not familiar as perhaps council
armitages with the exact wording of the
appeal decision
um but i again this is an application
for an extension
so i don't believe that the appeal
decision that cancer rnt
is referring to is directly um pertinent
to how you consider an application for
an extension to the property
right to say something first william if
before
we have had a site visit on this which
was for the um
previous application and this is an
exceptionally
large plot um so there would be more
than
ample room to even add to a turning
circle there
not like plus the drive that is already
there
and for people to come in and out easily
there's been no mention in here about
the hedge being removed in fact it's the
condition that the hedges days
and where the extension is actually
going to be placed
it wouldn't have much of an impact on
mrs kanpai
at all i would suggest one of the
conditions i would like to see
in there is maybe that where that hedge
is
thinner it could be thickened up but
this is covered in the extension
in the conditions rather so this this is
um
one one plot that is rather large
and really it's a shame people couldn't
go and actually view it because i think
you'd get a far better
reasoning and understanding of how it's
cited
william uh yes thank you chair
uh it was really uh you know if if we
could have made
it we're gonna have uh obviously another
bedroom
so there could be another couple of cars
or another car
and parking space on the on this plan
is a bit small for actually turning
uh and coming out
in a forward gear and i think
there should be uh an area in front
of the uh well to the to the left
where they felt all those trees uh
of the garage on the site
uh which could be uh made so that
more there was more parking space
bearing in mind
that the uh there are going to be
obviously more
uh inhabitants of the property
and also the fact that the
new extension uh states as
an integral part of the building
and has to remain that way and not to be
sold off as another residence
uh chair if i may um some of the points
that you've made very very briefly if
members are concerned about
the need for some beefing up of the
hedgerow condition
three could be an amended share to
require submission of those details
agreement and then
implementation if members are concerned
about the issue the council armitage is
raised regarding provision of a turning
area
that too could be condition chair and
also finally the issue about
the extension if permitted remaining
ancillary to the house
again as we've just discussed in terms
of the drop of application chair
and a condition could be a chat attached
for belt and braces to require that
although for any use of this property
there's two dwellings that would be
something that would require permission
in its own right so i think all those
issues chair could be
addressed by um condition if members are
otherwise satisfied chair
thank you councillor foster
yeah thank you chair uh if councillor
armitage is happy with those
um those three conditions
being added the turning circle the fact
that it can't be separated
um sorry i missed the other one if
council armitage is happy with those
three i'd be happy to support emotion
to to grant permission with those three
considerations
i'm quite happy to uh second that thank
you then we can move on and i've
seen that if council armitage is happy i
said okay
okay
because i know at one point it had just
about disappeared
uh if it could be conditioned uh that
uh where it's uh well it's got the on
the plan there's a yellow
part which said uh is to be uh looked at
it's to be
conditioned uh could it be extended
uh to go across the whole uh
distance yeah um
if if otherwise members
um are happy and that's the only issue
that's outstanding then you could do
that but
as an officer my advice has to be that
you should be considering this
application
and not seeking to address other issues
by condition
on the application before you that's for
the extension
so the proviso is that if you are
satisfied otherwise and you do want
hedging all along that boundary with the
property
um that backs on to um
the cottage that's mrs camcar's property
you could impose a condition on that
but in my mind that would go beyond um
reasonableness in this case because the
the area that i think counselor armitage
is concerning about is
is some considerable distance from where
the extension is
but i'm in your hands jay thank you
i think one of the things which came up
uh from
mrs camcar was the fact about a privacy
well if that hedge is uh
if the conditions put on to the existing
hedge
as it is at the moment then uh i can't
see a problem with the privacy
factor uh bearing in mind that there
were
a number of substantial trees on that
side
which have been felt already there's
nothing you know if you're not going to
protect the hedge the hedge could end up
being
held and also you've got the wildlife
aspect as well
so yeah just keen not to misunderstand
members in
in um taking your vote in a few few
seconds timeshare
as councillor foster's um just outlined
the issue regarding ancillary nature of
the extension turning around clear on
those
but i would need to be clear chair if
you minded to grant consent whether
you would want a landscaping scheme that
incorporated
additional hedging across the entire
boundary or just
as set out on the plan as annex won the
report
which outlines an area in red that
officers believe is directly associated
with the extension but again chair i
mean i mean your hands just need
to clarity from from you and members
chair if you might need to grant
permission
in respect of those conditions and
specifically the one regarding the hedge
stroke landscaping
adrian could we just see the picture of
the head again so
council members are clear about the
hedge
we're very much reliant on nikki i'm
very grateful to her for
orchestrating the presentation because
the technicalities of the
um screen sharing are are a bit beyond
my my my iti's ability so very grateful
to nikki for
for doing all this chair um just in if
you can
keep going nikki please uh
just get it there's just one below there
that's that's a good one
as you can see chair that's the area of
hedgerow that i believe
um you're referring to where there are
some
bits and pieces of gaps and you would
want the hedging retained although as
officers
set out i think the the application the
extension would be acceptable even
without the retention of the hedge but
notwithstanding that chair officers have
responded to the
comments made and looking to retain that
um
hedgerow if you just go back um a few
nicky i don't know just the one with the
garage on
that one there please just behind there
chair i think is the area that
councillor armitage is referring to
it's some distance away from the
hedgehog the extension
so isn't directly in an officer opinion
related
to it however as i keep on saying i
don't want to
unnecessarily prolong discussion debate
on the application
and we're in office and we're in members
hands if members
um are asking for the planting
of some boundary hedging or
trees along there then i just need
clarity on that sharing framing
any condition should you might need to
grant permission for the extension
could we just go to slide 29 nikki
because that's about
thank you so the extension is actually
going
here that this where the but factually
where the pile of rocks are
that's right yes chair so that's the
opposite end of
mrs cancar's property isn't it yeah mrs
camcar's property isn't that one that
you can see the roof of there together
that says alice's explain that
sorry that's a better one so the full
hedging
right at the far side is a full thick
hedge
which isn't being um taken out etc
so she's still got her privacy now
so her previously wouldn't be
interrupted by an extension at this end
of the building
certainly officer opinion chair and
that's um that's uh
um retained in in greater level by the
retention of the hedgerow although as i
say officers
would take the view that even without
the hedgerow the impact on
on the property next door that mrs
kamkar resides and
wouldn't be impacted on because the
property itself is some considerable
distance away from this point
that that area beyond the hedge there is
is the garden to that property and some
distance away from it as members will
see on the
location planning that papers thank you
thank you
i'm not wishing to necessarily prolong
discussion on this
just need to be clear what members are
minded should you be
finding to grant permission okay
councillor barry
yes all i was going to say really when
you look at that picture of
uh number 29 it looks like there's you
can see slightly through the hedging so
i take it what williams after
is for some infill planting to take
place at that particular area there's a
small wooden fencing
that um i think what woolen would want
is some trees planting
some hedging planting at that particular
area
which would mean that they couldn't see
through as it is at the minute you could
perhaps see through there if you went
right up to the hedge to see next door
so is that what you're saying william
and that area is what you want to be
filled in uh well the the thing is that
hedge
there is that gap which is as much as
you can see
but then the hedge then continues
all the way along and uh
before substantial trees were felt in
one thing and another and
there would be no protection to stop the
hedge being
fell and i i you know i think we should
have
respect the uh privacy of the neighbor
and retain the whole of that hedge
and not just the one in yellow because
you can't actually see
unless you've actually been on the side
and looked behind
uh you will see i think it's just in uh
on the actual plan it does show
after the yellow it does show there is a
hedge
and i would look i would like that to be
retained
right thank you so we can move on then
are there any further questions no are
we ready for a motion
just the one point chair just on the
hedging i'm taking the
the um vote you're taking is based on
would be based on the officer
recommendation chair but with the
conditions regarding ancillary nature of
the extension
the turning provision of attorney area
and
the landscaping of the site along the
entire
southern boundary chair and not just the
area outlined in red in your papers
that's that's the way that i'm reading
the debate and the discussion
yes thank you on that basis that you
have a motion which has been moved and
seconded
to approve of a recommendation officer
recommendations
on the basis of those discussions which
are sorry uh
um um sort of conditions which agents
just
specified yeah that's fine so we go
oh is everyone happy we're going to go
to the vote thank you nikki
so sorry yeah thank you chair
uh can we make sure we've got those
conditions correct and before it's uh
the planning manager is in touch with
council armitage to make sure we've got
exactly what we need on those uh
on that hedging could ask for that
that's fine i'd suggest chair that um
if cancer fosters happy with this that
the motion it means the money to grant
permission it's
subject to those those conditions inc
delegated to myself in consultation with
yourself chair
counselor barriers vice chair and cancer
armitage
chair okay thank you
off we go then nikki thank you um i'll
read members names in alphabetical
order if you could indicate clearly
fought against or abstain
counselor william armitage
councillor jane barry for councillor
andrew cooper
or counselor mark foster
councillor carol huckabee
follow me one moment would you own me to
counselor huckabee
four against or abstain counselor
huckabee
uh four
counts of the mopots or
councillor alan powell or
councillor tracy reader for
councillor jackie bridgeway for
councillor kathy rouse or
counselor diana four
and councillor roshitman that's 12 votes
for
chair that's carried thank you thank you
everybody
i've seen some flashing messages for a
short break
if i say um if we're back here for what
i don't think they'd have time to get
there then uh 10 minutes
is everyone happy with that so back at
uh
10 to 10
thank you
to the feed is now live thank you
we'll start the final application for
this morning
and that is for ned forward slash
20 forward slash zero zero two eight
five four with slash
fl and this is the change of use for a
menage to commercial sale of vehicles
effects affecting setting of a listed
building
over to the planning officer thanks to
chair
uh nikki if we could have the first
slide of the presentation up please
while that's happening chair we've in
receipt of
late representations which are included
in the late reports and members
hopefully you've had a chance to have a
quick look through those
clarity this application is for the
change of use of a riding arena to the
commercial sail of vehicles
in this instance campervans the site
sits to the south of a list of building
an
open countryside closely related to the
settlements of sherland
access is taken along a track which will
be modified to allow easier access
and passing within the site the main
planning considerations for you
are the for this application are the
suitability of the proposal in this
location
in policy terms its effect on the
character and appearance of the site and
the surrounding street scene
the impact upon the nearby listed
building the impact on the privacy
and immunity of neighboring residents
and land users
along with highway safety matters
officers do not consider that there are
any technical reasons to refuse this
application
and subject to a number of conditions
outlined in the report
officers recommend approval of the
proposed development
now this slide this shows the
application site shaded in orange on the
plan
the site sits in sherland off main road
which connects alfredton to the south
clay cross to the north
the applicant's property just to the
north west on the corner of
main road in town and that is a listed
building
and the to the south of that there is an
orchard with a number of protected trees
and as you see open countryside sits to
the east
east of the site and there are a number
of properties just to the south of the
access which you can probably just make
out on that plan
so if we move to the next slide please
this is the submitted location plan with
the site edged in red
or the land under the applicants
ownership is edged in blue as you can
see that extends
to the north west and to the east of the
application site
next slide please this block plan
illustrates the area to be used for the
proposed storage and sale of vehicles
you can see space within the site is
limited and the access track which leads
from main road to the west
sweeps up and around the application
site and also leads to the
applicant's property next slide please
this is an updated block plan of the
site and it illustrates the
location of a laurel hedge marked in
green
along the northern edge of the access
the proposal is to remove the first 21
meters
of the hedge to allow for a wider access
and a passing place
a section of hedge between the passing
place illustrated on this plan
and the building to the east will be
retained
next slide please
this is an enhanced block plan provided
by the applicant
and just perhaps shows a little bit more
clarity of the existing
planting in around the site and the
relationship with the neighbouring
property to the southwest
next slide please now these are the
photos taken from
site this photo is taken from opposite
the application site on main road you
can see the laurel hedge
in question just the left of the silver
car and before the wall
now behind that hedge there is a the
wall continues
down into the site and it forms the rear
kind of boundary of the orchard
as discussed earlier a section of about
21 meters of the hedge which is a laurel
hedge will be removed
next slide please
this is taken from the entrance looking
south along main road
next slide please this is a view taken
north you can just
this is a historic photo taken from
google uh just taken
to the north as you see town end is kind
of behind the
bus which is seen in the photo there
next slide please
this photo shows the context of the site
entrance and the neighboring property
a fence a load fence separates the two
until it rises to about 1.8 meters and
then continues all the way down the
access track next slide please
this has been taken from looking within
the site looking back west
along the access track as you can see
the the fence probably extends to
about two meters in height at this point
next slide please this is just taken
from a little bit further around the
bend so it starts to bend to the north
towards the application property and the
application
site as you can see the fence continues
along this boundary
next slide please this photo is taken
looking west from the access track into
the riding arena
as you can see the site is surrounded by
mature tree planting
some of these trees are protected just
to be clear no trees will be removed as
a result of the proposed developments
next slide please
this is one of a few photos that i've
got from within the site
looking this looks south west back
towards the neighboring properties
next slide please
this is looking south back towards out
buildings that you can probably just
make out the roof above one of those
tractors
that's just one of the outbuildings of
the neighboring property
next slide please yeah this is another
angle taken from the northwest corner of
the riding arena looking
southeast next slide please
this is taken again from in the riding
arena and this is looking back towards
the applicant's property the
listed building on town and as you can
see views from the riding arena back
towards the
applicant's property and list of
building uh you know a near on
impossible from within the site and the
final photo please
this is just taken from within the site
looking east towards the open
countryside and you see the
the high fence terminates probably just
behind the hedging that you can see on
the right hand side and then it opens up
with
post and rail fencing and you know
you've got a glimpsing view into the
open countryside
the chair that just concludes my
presentation
thank you
[Music]
thank you okay there we go
are there any questions at this stage
no fair enough um
i would ask the principal clark now to
read out the protocol for the
next part of the meeting
you're still on mute alan
do you apologize for that shirt
yeah essentially sure the uh next stage
will be
uh for the speaker uh to address the
committee
and i believe we only have one speaker
on this item uh councillor
in their capacity as ward counsellor
thank you councillor liggett if you'd
like to
address the council you have three
minutes thank you diana
good afternoon everybody i asked for
this application to be heard by
committee for several reasons
one its position in the centre of a
residential area
in the middle of the village and in the
grounds of one of the only grade two
listed properties in the village
it does seem a very strange place to
position such a commercial business
but my main reason is probably not
legally wrong
but morally wrong to pass an application
that uses a shared access
both mr and mrs hind in the neighboring
property that you saw on the pictures
and the bungalow next to them both
families use this access road and both
families have lived there for 20 years
and both families are extremely stressed
by the application
i'm also concerned about the removing of
the 21 metres of hedge even if
it is not a native head it is still a
wildlife habitat
condition 7.4 states local pound policy
be9 where appropriate the retention of
trees and other landscaping features
then in 7.8 it asks for 21 metres of
hedgerow
to be removed to widen the access
also due to the position of the entrance
onto the a61
on a sharp corner and at the brow of a
hill
and with such a narrow opening getting
large
vehicles especially low loaders which is
suggested
would be very difficult damn near
impossible i would say
it just seems a very strange place to
run this sort of business from
whilst causing great distress to the
residents next door
even highways in 4.2 have raised
concerns relating to the access
width as you saw it is a single track
road
thank you
thank you councillor are there any
questions at this stage
counselor shipman
thank you chair i just wondered if
council ligger thought because obviously
if this were to be passed there would
need to be access to the
site would it be more beneficial to for
the
hedgerow to remain and for it to be
single access
or do you believe cancelling that it
might be worth actually those
hedgerows coming out and they've been
replaced elsewhere i'm just thinking
for me i think you'd have to almost move
the hedgerows
because you'd have to have a passing
point to enter that site
because i'm struggling to find planning
reasons as to why you
you couldn't at the moment obviously
we'll learn more as things are going but
i'm struggling to find planning reasons
why you could reject this proposal
because it's an unused menagerie um
and access having access to a particular
road doesn't necessarily
negate any plan applications that would
require the same bit of road
so i'm just thinking what would a way
around some of your concerns be to
to to that we could add as conditions
potentially if it was passed
i i don't really think
removing the hedge is going to make an
awful lot of difference because that
head
is not that wide
um it has been there for at least 20
years
but i really don't think it will make a
lot of difference to actually pulling
out at the safety of pulling out onto
the a61
because it is rather a nasty junction
anyway um
[Music]
my main issues are
are we really going to get what we're
being asked here because
it doesn't quite ring true and when this
application first went in
it was just for band storage the
neighbors were so concerned they asked
me to
bring it in um and then it was changed
to balance sales which is what they
suspected was going to happen
all along um also the amount of
vehicles that um the applicant is saying
that we'll be visiting
doesn't seem to make any sense to me one
or two
a week one or two customers i don't see
how you can be running a commercial
business like that
it just seems a little bit strange to me
which is another reason we've brought it
forward thank you
this is to the clerk clark is is this
where the letter i gave you this morning
is uh
relevant
and just give me a moment please i think
it might be for this afternoon
i just wanted to tell you yes
we'll listen to mark foster first
council foster
thank you chair um we've got um
in the paperwork we've got uh a
statement saying there'll be no more
than five
vehicle deliveries per week and
customer appointments to the site should
be limited to one per day
um that on the uh on this on on the
facebook it doesn't seem like an awful
lot
um if we were to grant permission for
uh this application could that be put in
the conditions something like that some
sort of a
i don't know restriction um
what i'm thinking of is before when it
were used as a as a menagerie with the
horses and what have you
that you'd you'd be having those sorts
of that sort of traffic anyway along
this lane
thank you yeah thank you
okay are there any further questions
that was a chair that was a question to
the planning manager could we put these
right okay yeah if
the if i may the um issues i believe
that um
council fosters raising chair are set
out as recommended conditions within the
um office of recommendation in terms of
the deliveries
um sorry the number of visitors
that's um condition 10 chair
and deliveries are nine
that's nine and the
um a point was only taking place between
certain time limits that's condition 12.
and they are all
um and graham will correct from wrong
keychain they're all taken from the
applicant
submission that's been made and
i believe could be could be enforceable
but perhaps to
address one of the points that um
council ligget made in terms of
how the business will operate as set out
in
the uh initial paragraphs of the report
um its paragraph
2.7 chair um
these hilton negotiations it is designed
to take place online and over the phone
primarily so it's a number of businesses
that i know of some within
northeast somewhere outside there's more
and more of this
activity taking place online um and so
it's intended to be operated on that
basis hence the
restrictions that the applicants have
put forward as to why the limited number
of customers and visitors
will be necessary to visit the site but
also the point that counts that
fosters may chair in terms of the
previous use that's also something that
um you need to be minded of that there
is an extern permission for use of the
the site as a menage and certainly
vehicles going to and from
there will be and potentially
articulated in nature so
that's also a consideration chair one
thing to
just pick up is in the late reps the
applicant has requested just a little
bit more flexibility with the
appointments rather than one per day
he's requesting
six per week and no more than three in
one day
and what we've done is we've amended
condition 10 just to make sure that
there's no overlap
and there's gap between appointments so
the scale of
of operation will still be quite limited
and also about the habitat mitigation
you know we could look at
perhaps some replanting of some habitat
or
some native hedgerow elsewhere in the
site perhaps
thank you councillor shipman
yeah just on what greg grimes has said i
would like actually that to be the case
in terms of the native hedgerow perhaps
around the site to help with um
blocking the site off from people
looking into the site
uh because obviously with the being a
conservation area quite close by
if we can almost put native edge row
there to get any of this remote
personally i'd like to see the hedgerow
stay along that lane because ultimately
it's a it's a one-way road anyway
you know uh horse boxes and stuff would
have been going up there anyway with the
hedgerow in place
so to me it's destroying a habitat for
the sake of what
i don't i don't see the benefits there
actually weren't
the removal of that i drove but if we
are doing that then certainly it needs
to be replaced elsewhere on the side
i would probably suggest there's a
condition that's put around the site
itself to
block any view into it
thank you planning officer want to come
back on that
certainly uh that's um that's fine chair
we could we could add on
casper shipment believes it addresses a
point to to require
a planting landscaping scheme um and
having uh landscaping around that
may be the most apparently as graham's
pointed out
getting some native species as opposed
to the the laurel maybe an appropriate
way forward hopefully council [ __ ]
i think that addresses these concerns
thank you councillor parts
thank you chair um i've got two
questions do you want me to do them both
together or separately
just am i allowed to
um the first one is about the actual
proposal description
uh because it though within the planning
application it does
um indicate that this is for the sale of
campervans
but the actual proposal description uh
refers to commercial sale of vehicles
vehicles um and a quick google of right
van limited
does say that they deal in vehicles
ranging from vans up to seven and a half
ton trucks
um i don't know how big a seven and a
half ton
truck is but it sounds very big to me um
so if we are going to be asked to vote
on the the
commercial sale of general vehicles how
are we going to ensure
that um we're not going to have 7.5 ton
trucks being driven up that access road
that's the first question and the second
one relates to
car parking spaces within the site um
it says 20 spaces would be provided
um but the plan only illustrates
space for seven cars if there's only one
customer at a time coming in
why do we need space for 27
or 20 cars or does that include the
spaces for the vehicles that are up for
sale
thank you
is it graham yeah adrian i don't know if
you want to
perhaps chip in on this one as well so
the area of parking i think that's just
purely illustrative
on the plan so what we've done is we've
asked for a scheme of
parking customer parking and maneuvering
area to be submitted
and approved by the lpa as a condition
that's condition six
now that will just clarify which areas
will be used for parking which should be
kept clear
to stop people parking you know the vans
and
where will be the area of sales within
the site
with regards to the size of the vehicles
the proposal is for
vehicle sales and as you as you can say
we've tried to
limit the use to the operator and owner
of
the property and we've restricted to the
storage and sales of vehicles now that
that's
that's what we can do under this
proposal i don't know if adrian you can
perhaps guide me a bit further
perhaps about the size of vehicles maybe
limiting that i think that the point
that
cancer partnership makes is is valid
chair and
it's clearly a consideration that the
the condition
three um would limit the um site
to be the storage and sell of vehicles
only so there could be any vehicles but
if
council parts was particularly concerned
about about that issue
and yes it could be controlled to allow
only for the storage and seller vehicles
to a certain
level and if um caster pots has any
thoughts or concerns about that that
could be controlled through condition
and be enforceable
the the point though that graham's just
made up i think they
they are issues that we've we've
considered first of all
the area of the application site that
the menage that
what would be the former menage is self
limiting of the number of vehicles that
would be able to
be placed on the site it clearly
couldn't extend
beyond the application site and as
you've seen on the photographs
the site is very well contained in my
view
by um large planting and trees
and so there would be an element of self
limitation then also as graeme's pointed
out the
conditions would require that the site
is only operated by
owners of the property itself to town
end
so you wouldn't have other workers or
other people operating on the site
coming
to the site so again there's a self
limitation there
so if if members are concerned about
um the the size of the vehicles visiting
the site and that could be controlled by
condition
um but as of as officers we've taken
into account the existing use potential
for vehicles to go to and from anyway
and then the conditions that the grains
outlined do
provide an element of self-regulation
and
self-regulation the capacity of vehicles
that couldn't come and go from the site
thank you councillor pots is that okay
yeah as i say i don't have technical
knowledge to be able to say
limited to vehicles of a certain weight
but
when i look at um one of the pictures
that
you showed in the presentation of the
car coming out
um it does concern me that if there
isn't a restriction put on the size of
the vehicles any enormous
truck coming out of there i mean because
you do have to cross the the pavement
and i am concerned about pedestrian
safety um
at that access point
okay thank you councillor foster
uh thank you chair yeah further to uh
what council pots has said uh i've got
two
two questions uh the first one in
relation to council parts
the planning manager replied uh
conditions could be put on
restricting vehicles to a certain level
so to a certain level that's not weight
yeah but to a certain level that was
what it was defined um
in the proposal it speaks about wanting
to buy and sell
high-end camper vans and yet everything
in the conditions is relating to vehicle
sales
so if the proposal was for uh vehicle
sales we'd look at this differently i
think but because we're the proposals
for high-end camper vans
i believe that the definition should
also be high-end camper vans
and not just vehicles so not vehicles
relate
relating up to seven and a half ton or
any of the the weight limits
so excluding commercial vehicles
excluding them and
could we just define it with camper vans
conditions so high-end camper vans as
per the proposal
so could the conditions be relate to the
actual proposal
and that's the first one the second one
related to this
when it comes to signage outside
at the end of the lane what i wouldn't
want to do
is them to have a sign that said vehicle
sales on it
now that would be to stop people just
stopping by without appointments because
the original proposal
uh in the conditions are um
did we say up to six uh a week now what
we what i wouldn't want to do is
encourage people stopping by so if it
said
uh jblogs uh campervan sales
people would drive down there or they
park on that road and they'd walk down
that lane or they'd drive down that lane
so is that so there's two questions
there the second one is could we could
it be a condition where we
made it clear that you can't put
campervan sales or vehicle sales on the
outside of that lane
just the name thank you
planning officer yeah i think i'm um i
think i'm
i assume you can hear me chair i've got
the controls right and graham i'm sure
i'll come in
if i'm wrong first of all on the issue
of the
size of the vehicle
dumb vehicle expert but i understand 7.5
tonnes would be what i would understand
to be a luton
gluten-sized um lorry so not one of the
the large
hdbs but of a certain size um
just an answer to the comments that
council fosters made
i do believe that the planning condition
could um be fined and written
to limit the sales to campervans only
but it would need to be something along
the lines of vehicles designed
for um it would need to be precise
enough for vehicles designed for camping
to allow for
i'm not sure if living in is the right
word but anyway holidaying you know
living in i'm sure members understand
what i'm
what i'm trying to say so a condition
could be placed on
um any commission to that effect i
believe
but it would need to be very tightly
written if that's with members concerned
yes i do believe that could be contained
in the condition just into i hope i've
got this this right
council boston and do i apologize if i
haven't
i think your concern is about
advertisements generally
advertising the business on the roadside
if it is then that would be controlled
through the advertisement regulations
requiring
permission for signs over above certain
sizes but there is
committed rights for certain certain
size
adverts to be constructed under what is
the equivalent for adverts of committed
development so not
needing the consent of the council so um
that would be committed without coming
to the council but over above that
consent would be required for any
signage
on that and just to come back on that
chair uh could could it be a condition
that it's that they don't include
camperman sales
on the on the sign could that be a
condition all right
i apologize i think i did under uh i did
misunderstand that
um the content of the signage no that
couldn't be controlled
the the wording or whatever couldn't be
controlled
on the uh on the sign the the content of
the signage is not something that's
within our within our powers the general
design
nature size etc would be if it required
the consent of the council but we
couldn't specify certain words
aren't written or set out on that
signage
counselor shipment yeah if i can just
follow on from what council of foster
was saying about the uh
limiting it to campervans i think that's
probably the wrong thing to limit i
think you need to limit the size
because it's the size which is trying to
get down the lane
it's not you know whether it's a
campervan or a lottery i think we need
to limit
the size of vehicles so it's not having
an adverse effect on the
residents that are along that lane uh
because we can
say right you you know only camper vans
but then they bring a
eight and a half trucks on truck lane
and it causes it's causing avec so i
think
i'm less concerned about what it is
they're selling and i'm more concerned
about
causing aggro to the residents along
that lane um so i would put
you know whether it's the seven half ton
uh limit we'll put on it or whatever
i mean looking at the size of seven and
often vehicles they are the smallest
type of
trucks if you like seven and a half tons
they are pretty big trucks though
um but they seem to be the smaller end
of
if the different truck sizes um so i'll
probably perhaps just put it under
something
often to be honest with you at the limit
um
just so it stops you know so it will be
uh campervans but they're not be and
there might be some trucks
but they might not necessarily be the
massive seven and a half ton trucks it
might just be the box fans
nikki is it worth bringing up the
presentation do you show a photo of the
track because the track is very
self-limiting in the
kind of size of vehicle that can
actually get down there
because of the bend that that occurs and
they're not they're not
proposing to make any changes to the
access track so yeah that's a good photo
so that perhaps just helps members a
little bit that one and the previous
previous frame those two photos might be
quite useful and
it's quite kind of self-regulating the
access
hopefully that's helpful to members
thank you um councillor cooper
been very patient thank you
um it's along the same lines as
many of my colleagues basically first
and foremost to the officers
um is there a limit to how many vehicles
can actually be stored on
site that's first question and secondly
um i know it says no more than five
deliveries per
week but once again going along the same
same track as many of the other many of
their colleagues
the size of delivery and a delivery may
mean
to some people one vehicle
is it restricted to one vehicle or could
they end up bringing two vehicles per
delivery
i.e five ends up being ten as opposed to
five ends up being five and in order to
of
try and help the neighbors who live also
with access on that lane could they not
notify the neighbours of when those
deliveries are going to take place
and the days that they're going to take
place
thank you back to the planning offices
and uh i'll ask graham to um to advise
me for
the um things for the clarification is
needed
chair the way that i read
condition nine is that it's five vehicle
deliveries per week not
five vehicles delivered per week so i
think there's that issue that
accounts cooper raised which is is a
relevant chain if
um members are concerned about the
number of vehicles being stored on the
site at any one time
then now would be the time to to address
that
although i come back to what i said
earlier that the size of the menage
is as it is and um
will be self-limiting to an extent and i
don't think
many seven and a half ton trucks would
actually be
we could could actually get into the
site let alone be stored on the
the menage itself and i think my
my view just um speaking as
as as the debates going on is that if
members are concerned about
the numbers of vehicles on the site
it would be a better way of dealing with
that
it would be belt in braces again chair
because the application site is the
application side
but the belt embraces condition to say
that no vehicles will be stored
anywhere else on the connection with the
business will be stored anywhere else on
the
the application on the applicant's land
holding which would then
mean they're all contained within that
red line area
just um on the second point that
councilor cooper made about
advising neighbours i don't
believe jenny may have something to say
on this but i don't believe that is
a condition that would be enforceable
or controllable by ourselves so i don't
think it would pass the tests
i think that would just be a good navy
thing that we could
encourage the applicant to do but i
don't think we could appropriately
control that through
through condition chair i hope that
addresses the point so councillor cooper
would happily come back if
i've not answered all the points
thank you adrian councillor reader
uh yes chad i was just gonna say um i'm
finding i'm agreeing with council
shipment i think
i'm not overly concerned about what the
business is it's more about how we can
support the neighbours um i think
there are some horse boxers which are
around seven and a half tons so i think
probably horse boxers would have been
going down that track
of a similar size to the to the seven
and a half ton that everybody's talking
about so i think we've got to kind of
bear that in mind as well
um but adrian i was just wondering it's
very similar to what maybe council
cooper was saying was
can you um restrict the timings of
deliveries
done the the second point first chair
the
deliveries um and appointments would be
limited by condition 12
as has proposed which restricts
appointments and deliveries to the site
between eight o'clock and six o'clock on
monday and friday and then on a saturday
morning
and members may have a view on that and
and you're at liberty if you don't feel
they are appropriate to
to change them of course well that's
currently how they would be limited so
there would be no
um deliveries or appointments on any
sunday or bank holiday
and i'm the first point that counts the
reader may
chair i think limiting
the vehicles that could be on site in
connection with the business
to seven and a half tons would be
um it would meet the test because i
think that would be clear and precise
and therefore easily enforceable i think
everyone has some understanding
clearance only what seven and a half ton
trucks are um and i i'm not
uh a horse owner or a rider so i i don't
know about the
the details of that but i would agree um
see what i'm seeing on
the pictures i've got up here is that um
some of the horse boxes can be pretty
big
but again i come back to the point that
the track and the bend in the track and
the sight area
itself will be to an external extent
self-limiting on the size and number of
vehicles that can actually get into the
site and be stored there so i think that
is
um probably the the most determining
factor on what
vehicles can get into and how many will
be stored on site but i do think the
point the council really makes about
if members are concerned about the size
limited seven half
tons would be the easiest way of doing
that
thank you councillor armitage well
thank you very much uh chair uh
i would dare to say that i'm probably
one of the few
people on the committee who's ever
driven a seven and a half ton
vehicle uh now we all know what a car is
like and
easy to turn around like just for some
people
for a seven and a half ton well uh a big
uh lorry a seven and a half tuna takes
a hell of a lot of maneuvering to turn
around in that sort of area
the other thing which we're talking
about
high-end uh camper vans now
we've all seen the american ones uh
well you've probably seen them on the
road and they're much bigger
than a seven and a half ton but how they
get rounded is there's a lot of
aluminium parts on it so they get round
as a seven and a half ton and some of
these
you know mentioned about horse boxes
but these uh american ones are far
bigger
and they're much higher and we've seen
the trees overhanging
and what will happen is you just go
along and you rip the trees down
and that's what happens when you take a
vehicle that's too
big and because of the length you're
looking at some of these are 30 feet
long
and they haven't got a retractable
uh rear axle so you can swing them
around
and as a result you need a lot more
space
and with considering uh
a commercial uh establishment
uh in the countryside you know and
it's next to a listed building
and i think you've got to realize how
big
these vehicles are and it will be very
very difficult to legislate and
to police these vehicles and the size of
them
and i think it's you know this you can't
turn one round up there
very easily and that's just my point
thank you uh does the planning officers
want to come back on that
no any point i would make chair if i may
is that
your planning policy and um the policies
set out and the mppf i
think council shipment perhaps touched
on this at the very start of the
discussion
is that the policies don't preclude um
the the growth and expansion of
businesses in rural areas and that's
generally encouraged by
national and local policies but it's
done correctly and hence the discussion
we've had about the conditions which
hopefully is helpful to members if
you believe it is appropriate for the
business to go ahead and conditions may
be
and the way of controlling some of the
concerns that members have rather than
resisting the the application entirely
thank you councillor barry yeah i think
um
in mind after listening to what
everybody said to defer this application
until we can get more detail on the size
the weight
the width the length of all these
vehicles
that they're you know proposing to sell
um i'm all right about a business taking
place
but until i get more information on the
type
of vehicle that they're going to be
putting in there then i do have concerns
especially you know seven half ton like
um william was saying
takes a lot of maneuvering um and i'm
not sure the site is suitable for that
so i think
personally i'd like to make take motion
to sort of say to defer this
and ask the applicant to come back with
further detail
of the size shape and thing of the
vehicles that they want to actually sell
from this property
thank you before we move on to that as
councillor ridgeway
yeah it's just me i'm reading in point
eight that it says the business
um will be operated by the owner from
two town end
but if they're operating from eight am
to six pm
how do we know they're not going to
build anything a building on that site
to actually um do their business from i
mean i don't know what the distance is
from where they live
in walking distance or vehicle distance
to where they're going if it's a rainy
day are they going to stand outside
i mean i don't so i agree with jane i
think we need a little bit more
information
i'm just worried that you know they may
also want to build a little
shack or a little building on there so
that they can operate from the actual
site
itself
just just to be clear it's very well
related to the
applicant's property i turned up on site
at the entrance and within a few seconds
he'd walk to meet me
by walking all the way around the back
of the side so it's all very well
contained
all within one site and the the menage
kind of backs onto a
residential garden and the orchard that
we've discussed
just dad to that chair i appreciate
counselor
foster's um asking to speak just on the
back what graham's said chair
um two-town end is shown on the location
plan
at page 21 of the of the report and as
graeme says it's very well
related to the site it's all with land
within the ownership of two tenants all
contiguous
and in any case chair my understanding
is that if they did want to building
their
connection with the the business for a
variety of reasons it would require
planning consent
thank you i hope i'm getting this in the
right order
councillor shipman did you have your
hand up to speak
i was just about i mean graham's kind of
picked a point i was just about to say
what uh the
issues that council ridgeway and uh
barry have raised they're all within the
application itself they've said what
size vehicles they want
they're talking about it's appointment
only that's why they're not needing a
shack on the side because he lives
around the corner
and therefore he can just jump in his
you know you can just well should we
walk around the corner
um and i think we're just wasting
everyone's time if we defer it i think
we need to seem to make a decision now
either for it or against it for me i
don't see any planning reasons why we
can reject it
there's conditions we can put in place
which mitigate
you know how what size vehicles are
sending down the lane
and i think we can solve the issues
that are being raised thank you
councillor foster
uh thank you chair um it was more or
less what councillor shipman
uh said but i think he's put pretty much
better than i would have
um yeah i think everything's there in
the uh
in the actual conditions and i knew
earlier i said
uh camper vans and then we moved moved
towards
the seven and a half ton limit i'd still
be happy to stick on
camper vans because that's what the
original uh proposal was
if officers feel that the seven and a
half tons uh
would be uh give more protection uh
to the people that are concerned that
would be affected then yes
i'd be happy to look at a really uh
tight
uh definition of camper vans rather than
it being used for
uh other vans up to seven and a half ton
so rather than just being used for
vehicle sales the
the request from the applicant is for
high-end camper vans and they painted
the picture as such
i'd like to keep to that picture uh
still
if officers feel that seven and often
might be more appropriate
then yeah but for me uh high-end camper
vans i'd still be rolling with that
and then uh to follow up
also from what councillor shipman said
uh i don't think we need to defer this i
think we've got all we need on this and
there's a lot of work being done on it
and it's going to take more time and
more officers time
i think we've got enough here and also
right at the beginning we had
uh officers said there's no reasons to
reject this proposal we don't have any
reasons
you might have a reason to defer it yes
but there's no reasons to reject this
so i think we should go ahead and
i'll look at doing something with this
now
counselor barry i didn't say i was
rejecting
the thing i said i was actually for the
business side of this
my concerns are about the length and the
width
of a vehicle a campervan i agree um
you know you can define it how you want
but there are some extremely
long campervans and those long camper
vans will struggle to get
up there now he's not defined anywhere
that i can see
the size of you know in relation to the
length
of them so what i'm asking for is that
we get clarification and it can be
turned around quite quickly and i'm
happy then for it to go to delegated
decisions if need be
but i think we need to know more about
the length of these vehicles
because seven and a half ton can be
seven half tons in any which way you
want it to be
um and i agree the business i haven't
got a problem with the business
whatsoever
but i want more clarity on the length
and the width and the
weight of the vehicles and i think seven
and a half ton
is as much as you would want to put down
that driveway
and especially coming out onto a main
road
so i still do call for a deferral
okay over to the clock to sort that lot
out
with this stage um i'm not sure there's
much two souls out
um we've had uh councillor barry saying
that she would actually be in favor of
deferring the eisen i assume uh you're
moving that as a motion
hi i'm alan yeah yeah um and obviously
sort of we've yet to have anyone who
actually wishes to
second that motion i'll second it oh no
oh i was going to second it sorry right
right
no no you're fine you carry on
counsellor a chair that's fine i was
just gonna count um second it um
adrian wants to come in because
obviously if this is moving against
officer recommendations we need to be
clear as to the reasons
i just um just in terms of the deferral
uh
chair just need to be clear exactly what
it is that members
are asking officers to go and get
clarification on um
i've written down here um chair that its
members would want the specific
type of vehicle as councillor foster has
said the the application is for
um storage of vehicles but the
supporting information does talk about
in some explicit detail the primary use
being for high-end camper vans
so you need to be clear what additional
information you would want on that
um we talked about weight as discussed
with council reader i think there is a
condition that you could attach
to that it's only if you were concerned
about wanting to limit it to
to some other weight other than an axle
weight for example
um width um again i think the
track itself is a limiting factor on the
on the width and the
the turning of the the laying but and
that is a matter that members need to
assess but you do need to be clear
exactly what additional information
and the committee would want in order to
make a decision on the application
that's that's all it is just it members
our money to defer officers just need to
know what
members are asking us to go away and
seek additional clarification on
i think um when you say high end
uh camper funds those high-end camper
vans
are very long and i've got concerns
about
maneuvering those vehicles down that
lane
and i think there should definitely be a
condition on for the weight limit of
them
um and i'm just not sure that i can see
everything in here
to sort of make me feel comfortable that
some of these
high-end campervans aren't going to turn
up down here that are the ones that you
end up pulling out the sides or whatever
and causing a problem um getting out of
the access i just think the length of
the vehicle as much as anything else is
just as important
in relation to maneuvering in and out of
the site
just uh just again chad don't wish to
necessarily prolong the debate but
um if the length of the vehicles is is
so important
to the consideration to determination
application for whatever reason then yes
we can go and seek that
i do have some concern about how
um the enforceability of condition if we
are limiting the length of a vehicle
in a condition that is more difficult to
enforce than would be
for example the actual weight of the
vehicle
thank you i'm happy to second this
motion
on the the same reasons that um jane has
given
but also that it needn't come back to
the full council we could leave it to
delegated powers
if you're happy with the information you
then receive
yeah just on that that would be a
decision of
members of course if you were minded to
that i wouldn't wish that to be
delegated
straight to myself i'd want that in
conjunction with yourself and the vice
chair
yes just one that would be appropriate
counselor armitage all right see a
photograph
of one of these large camper vans
high-end
camper vans going in to that uh
junction going into that area and seeing
how big it looks in the actual meninage
thank you council reader
yeah i think i've already said it i
think the horse boxes have probably been
going up and down that lane
for quite a long time and usually horse
boxes can be pretty difficult to
maneuver
usually you can get some pretty long
ones that are attached to a vehicle as
well
so i i'm a bit concerned that we're
going down this route now to try and
defer this
i think there have been vehicles which
could equally be matched
to the size of of the seven and a half
ton
i think we could probably manage this
through
conditions like other colleagues have
said
so i i have to say i'm quite concerned
with this
okay do you need to retract your emotion
counselor barry i mean if everybody
doesn't feel the same as me that's fine
then we use our votes to say that don't
we so i've put a motion forward let's
vote on that motion if people don't want
to do that they'll vote against it
okay
over to the clock to put the motion
forward there is a motion chair so
should we move forward
yes please
thank you so the motion
i'm sorry to interrupt uh nicola uh just
quickly chair uh
uh a motorhome in the uk size of
motorhomes in the uk there's already a
restriction fit to be a motorhome and
it's 12 meters long which is long
but that is like a a horse box uh not a
horse box
uh a horse uh lorry if you like 12
meters long and 2.5 meters wide
that's already a restriction for
motorhomes
and seven and a half tons is one of the
limits that's why i still like the idea
of defining
uh motorhomes but uh sorry to interrupt
going to the vote but i just thought i'd
bring that in thank you back to you
nikki
i was just going to say just to be clear
we're talking here about um
deferral of the application
uh for the reasons set out in terms of
actually getting additional
information uh around the vehicle's
weight
with another such matters as discussed
uh with the intention
then that if satisfactory information is
received that this being a decision be
taken as a delegated decision
by the planning manager in consultation
with the chair
thank you i'll conduct the uh vote by
roll call if you could clearly say
um either fought against or abstain the
motion to defer
counsel william armitage
council jane barry for
councillor andrew cooper against
council mark foster against
councillor carol huckabee
that's the huckabee you'll need to mute
yourself
against counsellor mopots
against councillor alan powell
councillor tracy reader against
councillor jackie ridgeway four
councillor kathy rouse against
councillor diana ruff and councillor
ross shipman
against
chair i make that four votes four and
eight against which means the motion
falls
thank you is there any other motion on
the table
counselor shipment i'll move that it's
um approved subject to the
um conditions that the planners have
put in place as well as a
um these the weight was it
i mean adrian needs to clarify was it
the weight that you were saying that
would be easiest
to um police adrian
and i do um cancer shipment but also
um i don't if i'm on the same
information that
council fosters looking at but the the
there are different classes of motorhome
the largest being a class a which range
from
generally 21 feet up to 45 feet i don't
know what that is in
in metric but if members are
concerned about that we could certainly
um
place a condition on about the axle
weight of the
the vans but if members did want it
restricting to camper vans
only then i think we we could come up
with a um
a definition of that although i think it
has to be accepted that
um by members that some may actually
exceed
the uh the average lengths that there
are but we could
include both conditions if that's what
members wanted but yes
cancer shipments correct chair that
actual weight is by far and away the
easiest way of controlling
the size of vehicles from my point of
view i would just restrict the weight
itself i think
that you know you can convert vehicles
into campervans and it's just going to
get into a bit of a nightmare i just
think just keep it to the axle weight
you can police it quite easily
or easier should i say probably not
quite easy but you can police it a lot
better
and you know um let's hopefully that
that
restricts it enough for the residents
locally to uh not be
hindered too much there was also chair
previously discussion about an
additional
scheme regarding planting and
landscaping which i've noted which
officers would also add in
councillor foster thanks chair uh
if councillor shipman's uh happy
i've got the seven and a half ton i
understand that completely and it would
be easier
but councillor shipman also be happy to
include as well as that for a greater
safeguard to include the definition of
campervans i know they can be converted
um but you know i think it had a greater
uh that's what they've asked for and i
think the um
it that greater security and strengthen
those uh
those considerations would uh
would you be happy on that i i
i yes i mean i'm happy to accept that if
that's
if if this guy's honestly wants to think
what i don't want to do is restrict him
from it is business that's
that's my concern um but you know i'm
sure he can come back to us and ask for
an amendment a change of condition if
if that condition is not fully um happy
with
uh but yeah we will go with that
that would be uh be chair um
if members are minded to prove the
application a
condition limiting the sales from the
site
of to to campervans only notwithstanding
the other submitted details yeah
so that's three additional conditions
chair campervan sales
the axle weight and um the provision of
landscaping and it's implemented yeah
that's right
thank you
so is there anyone seconding them
councillor shipman's proposal
councillor foster thank you be over to
you nikki for the vote
thank you so you're voting to grant
planning permission subject to the
conditions discussed fought against or
abstain
counselor william armitage for
jane barry councillor andrew cooper
or asthma mark foster
council carol huckabee for
councillor mopots testing
counselor alan powell paul
councillor tracy reader or
counselor jackie ridgway against
councillor kathy rouse or
counselor diana ruff against
and councillor shipman
i make that eight votes for three
against with one absentian chair which
means the motion has been carried
thank you thank you all very much for
this morning
and we'll all see you back at just
before two o'clock thank you
you